GUILLAUME MARTIN:
Hello everyone,
and welcome to this
first live stream
from the NUMA studio in Paris.
I have with me
here Gary Cige who
is the entrepreneur in residence
at NUMA, and especially
at Le Camping, which
is the accelerator.
And Gary will shortly be
introducing our startups here.
Before that, I would like to
show you what NUMA looks like.
Could we please
switch to the image.
And so NUMA is a space
with multiple stories
for multiple activities
dealing with entrepreneurships
and startups.
And in the first floor at the
end of the co-working space,
we now have this studio.
This is what the plans
were looking like,
and this is what the
reality looked like.
Lots of cabling, lots of
boxes, lights, cameras,
lots of putting it all together.
This is the working equipment,
and the first recording,
and a studio that is now
ready for you and all
of the residents at NUMA to use.
Whoever wants to
broadcast their passion,
their competency, or
simply information
about their products,
can now use this studio
to broadcast to the world.
So Gary, can you
introduce our guests here?
GARY CIGE: I'd be happy to.
The first start up we're
going to be interviewing
is called REALITICS, which
is one of the 12 startups
that joined Le Camping
a couple of months ago.
It is a great adventure.
They will explain a bit what
happened during those last four
months.
Where did they come from?
So basically, REALITICS
is something very simple.
It is an analytics
platform dedicated
to TV advertisements and
TV advertising in general.
My first question
is quite simple.
It's what happened during
those last three months?
How did you arrive with
what kind of product.
And what has been evolving
for the last couple of months?
SEBASTIEN MONTEIL: This
is Sebastien speaking,
the founder of REALITICS.
Actually we came in at Le
Camping with a piece of paper
and an idea coming from a
previous experience in Kobojo,
a social gaming company where
we handled millions of users.
And we had a big issue to
understand them and analyze--
be a viewer in the game.
So we had an idea to create
a real time platform that
allowed us to understand
all the people.
And this is the way we
came into Le Camping.
But Guillaume will explain
what came after that.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: Yeah.
So I'm Guillaume,
the other co-founder.
Actually we are four.
And so when we first arrived at
Le Camping, what was very hard
was to actually pitch our
idea in a very short way,
because everybody needs
analytics but everybody
has different needs.
So Le Camping brings us a
lot of things-- mentorship,
a lot of network, and basically
we got out to the building.
We met people.
We talked with people.
We did it in the
least startup way.
And so we found out
that there was something
which is completely
unaddressed today,
which is analyzing the impact
of TV ads on online websites,
mobile apps, et cetera.
GARY CIGE: If I
recall, at first you
came with an idea which was
basically a big data analytics
tool, which was a bit
difficult to pitch.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: That's it.
GARY CIGE: And then, if
I remember well, the way
you previewed it was
basically that you
got some different demand from
a different type of client,
and you analyzed basically what
was the most needed solution
for that specific line.
And then you decided
to completely overhaul
the business you
were working on.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: Yeah we kept
the technical assets we had,
but as you mentioned
we completely
shifted from business analytics
to the TV ads landscape, which
is completely different with
different actors, et cetera.
And so we built our very
first MVP during Le Camping.
Since, well thanks to you,
thanks to all the people
we met, we had great
ideas and great feedback.
And this is most interesting.
MARTIN GORNER: You
mean that nobody
was interested in big
data and heavy [INAUDIBLE]
just for the sake of it.
GUILLAUME BELMAS:
Yes, they were, but--
MARTIN GORNER: They needed
at specific use case.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: They
were, but it's quite hard
to first arrive in a
big field like big data
with almost nothing to show.
While when we arrived
in the TV ads landscape
with the first piece
of technology we had,
we knew that we could build
a very valuable first product
for these people.
And that's what we did.
MARTIN GORNER: So show us.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: Yeah.
Sure.
So what you see here is the
detail of one TV ad spot.
What we do with
REALITICS is that we
track each and every TV
ad for an advertiser.
And we also have our
own analytics tracker.
So basically we deployed
our analytics tracker
on the platform.
And we have a very
[INAUDIBLE] that
allows us to track the
data on the minute scale.
GARY CIGE: Just to
explain, what you
call a granularity
is basically the fact
that you don't know only show
the visitors for a large period
of time, but basically for
a shorter period of time.
GUILLAUME BELMAS: Yes.
That's it.
Because when you do
drive to work TV ads,
people are with their
phones and tablets,
and they browse the
website of the advertiser.
So what we can do with
analyzing all the data is
to estimate very precisely how
many people came from the TV
ad, even if the TV is
completely a disconnected media,
we can track these people.
And here, as you
see, we have a lot
of people coming from
the TV, but we also
have the regular traffic.
And what we do is to compute
while the customer visit
in order for web marketers to
have the same data that they
have when they do a Facebook
ad campaign, or Google AdWords,
et cetera.
And we also track all the
impact on the business metrics
of their ads.
So here we have an
e-commerce website,
and we track the impact of these
ads on the lead, so basically
account creation,
and order, et cetera,
so we can track every
metric you need.
And we do this for
all the TV campaigns.
So we can basically
tell you which
channel is best for
your project, which
time slot, which
TV show, et cetera.
We can put all
the data together.
MARTIN GORNER: And
now this product,
you have validated
it with customers?
GUILLAUME BELMAS: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: They
are happy about this?
GUILLAUME BELMAS: We
have six customers today,
including [INAUDIBLE].
And they are running all
their TV ads with our platform
and they're very happy.
So we count on them
to spread the word
that we have a great
project for TV advertisers.
MARTIN GORNER:
Thank you very much.
Thank you Guillaume
and Sebastien.
And now we are heading to
another accelerator, the Le
Camping Toulouse accelerator.
From Le Camping we have
with us Guillaume Martin,
who founded PICTARINE,
which actually
is a start up that went through
Le Camping here in Paris.
And he has a story to tell us
about a radical pilot they did,
and ended up with an application
that allows you to print
your photos at the nearest
Walgreen's in the United
States, an application
that actually makes money.
GUILLAUME MARTIN:
And that's true.
MARTIN GORNER: Hello Guillaume.
GUILLAUME MARTIN: I
had a chance to go
through three different
[INAUDIBLE] programs
in my entrepreneur's life.
So first I joined Le Camping
in Paris about three years ago.
MARTIN GORNER: So what was
the business model back then?
GUILLAUME MARTIN: We were
a photo management website.
We basically enabled you
to upload or download
your photo from Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
and all of the usual
photo services.
MARTIN GORNER: So a social
photo aggregation service?
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Yeah.
We had the aggregation
part, the management part,
and we've made it
since this time,
and then two or
three times I think.
MARTIN GORNER: Gary,
as a specialist,
any opinion on this
business model?
GARY CIGE: No.
I think the issue when working
with different social networks
is it's always a bit tricky.
Because you get a
good business model
that doesn't
generate any revenue.
And I think Guillaume
realized quite quickly
that there was a good way
to use a social network
and derive basically
business from social media
directly to a
different business.
And I think it's
an amazing story.
I think they didn't take that
much time to realize that.
And I knew Guillaume very well.
And it's quite amazing.
I'm a bit curious about--
you've been testing and more
than testing the
product for a while now.
What are the current
results with the customers,
and the number of pictures let's
say uploaded-- or not something
that specific--
but basically what
have been the results of
the last couple of months
of operation with
that new product?
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Are you
talking about the last app
that we created?
GARY CIGE: Yeah.
GUILLAUME MARTIN: OK.
So basically from
the very first day
we had the chance to do earn
with this app, about $70 bucks,
which was more than what we
earned during four years.
So we knew we really
had something.
And at this time, we
were really focused
on making the user
experience awesome, which
we could do because
we previously
worked on another Android app.
And at the same time, we
really considered distribution
and user experience
at the same time.
And I think this is why the
app is so successful today.
MARTIN GORNER: How
did this happen?
You actually moved to
the US for a while.
You went through
another accelerator.
What was the switching
point at which
you made the right
contact and realized
there was a business
model after all?
GUILLAUME MARTIN:
The thing is-- yeah,
we had the chance to join
[INAUDIBLE] Chicago two
years ago.
And for us it was huge
because this place
was the first time
for me in the US.
So we were super
excited about that.
And the second thing
is they already
had us do work from a
website to a [INAUDIBLE].
And at the same
time, they enabled
us to change the
value proposition.
And the best thing
that we learned
there is how their user
experience is super important
and how the distribution is
[INAUDIBLE] the start of life.
And this is something that
people are missing here
in France, that distribution--
most people that
think that the hardest
thing about the startup
is to create the product.
But that's completely wrong.
The hardest thing
about the startup
is to get people to
use your product.
And we learned all these things
the hard wary during one year
and 1/2 in the US.
And when we found out that
there's already a real use
case with photo printing,
we nailed the experience,
we nailed the distribution.
And I think this
is why we managed
to get the success
with this app.
MARTIN GORNER: And so actually
now you have a revenue stream.
And as a result, you
moved back to Toulouse
and you're now the
resident entrepreneur
at Le Camping Toulouse
helping other startups.
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Yeah.
I'm really thankful about that.
I contacted them six months ago
when I moved back to France.
I chose Toulouse because
of the wine, and of course
because there was
a Camping here.
And I contacted them.
I told them, I'd like
to head some start ups.
So now I'm the entrepreneur
in residence here.
I'm having fun with
all the start ups here.
And this is great
because I can teach them
what I learned in the US.
And this is great because yeah.
MARTIN GORNER:
Thank you Guillaume.
Since you are the
resident entrepreneur,
feel free to pitch
in at any time
when we speak about
the other startups.
And before we switch to
David-- who is here--
I would like to fly again,
this time to Berlin.
So in Berlin, Google
for Entrepreneurs
has another partnership
similar to the one
we have here at NUMA.
This is the factory.
The factory actually underwent
a huge, huge renovation.
It used to be a brewery.
And the parts you see in brick
color are the original parts.
All the rest, so the additional
two stories, are brand new.
And the factory is
home to parties.
Well of course, this is Berlin.
And actually having Sound Cloud
as a resident at the factory
helped with the partying.
But the factory also has
a lot more residents.
The specificity-- I
will let Jeremy Bamberg,
who is the community
manager at the factory,
describe what is specific
about the selection of startups
you have.
Hello Jeremy.
JEREMY BAMBERG: Hi Martin.
Hello Paris.
Hello Toulouse.
How is everyone today?
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Good.
MARTIN GORNER: Cool.
JEREMY BAMBERG: I'm Jeremy,
from Berlin based factory.
We're a 16,000 square
meter technology campus
based in Berlin Mitte, right
next to the former Berlin Wall.
We house startups and
mature technology companies.
So some Martin has already
mentioned, like Sound Cloud.
Some other bigger Berlin
startups that are well known
are 6Wunderkinder.
They just received $19 million
of investment from Sequoia.
And then we also house some--
I would say maybe lesser
known-- startups if
you're outside of Berlin
and let's say based in France,
or somewhere else in Europe,
or somewhere outside.
I have Valentina from
URLI.ST right next to me.
VALENTINA: Hello.
JEREMY BAMBERG: We host many
other smaller stage teams
that have, let's say,
five to 10 people in them.
The interesting aspect
about us as well
is that we're looking for
different stage companies.
So we plan to host
Mozilla, and we
also international companies.
A few that have
signed on recently--
which I can't
unfortunately announce,
but you'll hear about
that soon-- but some
that are quite well known
like Zendesk, that's based out
of Silicon Valley,
and MyFitnessPal, also
a US based company.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you Jeremy.
And tell us a story about the
reconstruction of the building.
I know that while
digging out the courtyard
and underground parts you
found something amazing.
What was that?
JEREMY BAMBERG: So actually
we have quite a lot
planned for the area.
So we're a tech campus.
We have five buildings
right here, right now.
We're planning to
build another one.
The main building,
everything went fine.
Like you saw, Martin probably
showed a wonderful photo
of this brick facade
with two modern floors
stacked on top of it.
Directly next to
that right now we
were digging to build
a new, modern building,
and we actually found a bunker.
So we found a bunker that
was occupied by the Nazis,
and the Russians
tried to blow it up,
and now we're trying
blow it up to build
some programs supported by
Google for Entrepreneurs,
Factory, and other partners that
support entrepreneurship here
in Berlin.
So the historical
significance of that area,
we can see it right
outside our windows.
We're right next to the
Berlin Wall memorial.
And you can still see the
pegs from the former wall
right there.
MARTIN GORNER: So
let's switch to URLI.ST
or shall we call
it DevCharm now.
Hello, Valentina.
VALENTINA: Hello.
OK.
So I am the
co-founder of URLI.ST.
And URLI.ST is the product
that we built in the last year.
It was a social bookmarking
tool with a very diverse target,
with a wide target.
And the story is
that we built URLI.ST
but now we're pivoting
to other projects.
MARTIN GORNER: So URLI.ST
was all about curation.
Curation, a series of links
about any kinds of topics?
Yes.
VALENTINA: Yes.
But at some point after
the launch we worked on it,
but the performances
were not good enough.
I mean, we were no
satisfied with the numbers.
So we just learned
from that experience
and we pivoted to
another project that
is called DevCharm,
which is still curation,
but is directed to a
more precise target that
is a better place
for programmers.
So now we're building
this project basically.
And yes?
MARTIN GORNER: And
maybe before we
continue, Gary, do you have
any general advice on business
models based around curation?
GARY CIGE: Well curation
is quite tricky.
So I don't have advice
on any specific stuff.
But usually when something
is that complex, especially
curation, the best
way to act first
is not to reinvent the wheel.
Look at what has
been done before.
Usually in everything
which is linked
to curation-- it
could be Pinterest,
it could be another
type of platform--
the issue is that people want
to distinguish themselves
on different business models
that are not as efficient as it
should be.
And so what I
suggest is basically
to speak to people
that have been working
at different curation websites.
And just understand--
not especially
do exactly the same-- but
just understand the process
that they've been acting
through to see a bit
how they got to the
current business model.
This will probably not tell
you exactly what to do,
but at least it will
give you an insight
of the thing that they've tried
before and that didn't work.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
And before we
continue, I will make
a demo of what
DevCharm is today.
VALENTINA: Yes.
Because now online you
can see a first pilot
test, because
actually we changed
around our work process.
So instead of building
a problem from scratch,
we decided to build a
test that is now online.
So now we're working
on the real platform
that will be launched soon.
And that, that is
online, is a series
of articles, a list of links.
It's a combination of
resources about development.
And we wanted to test the
reach of the audience,
and we wanted to
test the interest,
and so that was our goal.
MARTIN GORNER: So let me
show that to our audience.
I'm here on DevCharm.
And actually the only way
to log in is through GitHub.
This is really for developers.
And when I logged
in, I have this.
So I have created
an accumulated list
of links, which is
about WebGL demos.
Here on my links.
I can switch to one of them.
This is what it looks like.
OK.
And now the most
amazing part, something
that I really found
great about your website
is the way you edit those links.
So this is the interface.
At first I was dismayed.
But actually for developers
and people used to GitHub,
this is great.
The only way to edit this
list is to actually type code.
I love typing code.
So here for instance, if I
want to change the title,
I go here, one WebGL.
Let's call this
great WebGL demos.
And here I go.
The same for all the rest
of the links and so on.
How did you come up with such
a radical user interface?
VALENTINA: Well the thing was
we had a very wide audience
with URLI.ST. And
we thought, OK, we
should analyze this audience
and make something different
and more targeted
to a specific one.
And since we were a
quite technical team,
and we knew that also our
audience-- actually of URLI.ST,
most of it was quite
technical too-- so
we decided just to
focus on developers.
And this is what comes from
our experience with URLI.ST,
that it's much,
much better to work
with a very precise
audience now,
because we can understand
better their needs.
So this is why we also
chose [INAUDIBLE] something
that looks like a text editor
when you edit your needs,
because it's more
comfortable for developers.
It's just the way
they want web stuff.
And we can [INAUDIBLE]
library that is wiki-based,
so you can edit
other people's lists,
and you can build together
with others these lists.
And this is also coming from
the experience of social coding.
So that was the
great improvement
that we made on working on a
project with a web consumer
approach and switching to
something that is more precise.
And also the attitude of
business model as well.
Because in this case,
it's much precise
also the business
model, because you
can build a job board that
is tied up into developers
and is tied up to the
content of the platform.
So for instance, it's much,
much more interesting and easy
actually to manage this idea.
GARY CIGE: Yeah.
It definitely has nothing to
do with the curation website
example I gave you.
But you're totally right.
I'm a bit curious about how
you tested the solution.
How did you begin
with that solution?
How do you disseminate the
product in the community?
Did you use the
factory, for example,
developers from the factory?
Did use online communities?
How did you manage
to basically test
the first version of the
product with your target?
VALENTINA: Well the
thing is, obviously
the factory is very
important for us
because it's such a
great community in terms
of technology.
I mean, we exchange a lot of
ideas with other teams here.
We [INAUDIBLE] team because we
are basically the same team.
And this made us think about our
text tech in a different way,
so we exchanged some solutions.
In the very beginning
we decided, OK,
instead of building
a product, we'll
build something
like a prototype.
So we built just a few
pages that were connected,
and we tested the reach
using [INAUDIBLE] and Reddit.
Because we wanted
to see if people
are interested in this content.
Are they willing to share it?
Because that was
the problem that we
had with the previous product.
They were not willing
to share as much.
It was more like
individual use, which
was making any sense for
us on our business model.
And so we just
gathered the numbers
and were like, OK, so this is
much more interesting in terms
of numbers compared
to what we had before.
And then we decided to
build something smaller
for our first steps.
So that was building a prototype
instead of a whole product,
and then deciding to go
for the platform we are now
[INAUDIBLE].
MARTIN GORNER: Thank
you very much Valentina.
This is a great adventure.
And we will now
continue the adventure
and go back to Toulouse.
In Toulouse we
have David with us.
David, who is the
founder of CityMeo.
And to show you what CityMeo is
about, let's play short movie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
David.
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
Hello.
MARTIN GORNER: Hello.
So the first time we met I said,
this is a Chromecast for shops.
And you told me, no, it's not.
So what is it?
DAVID KERIBIN: Yeah.
Like a Chromecast, but a
Chromecast [INAUDIBLE],
sort of.
MARTIN GORNER: No.
Actually it's very different.
And please tell us what
this connected object does.
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
In fact, at the
beginning of a our story,
a short story, because
it was one year ago we
had the chance to
participate and to take part
as a startup in
Toulouse and to pitch
the idea, the original
idea of CityMeo,
which was a sort
of social network.
But a physical one that
was based on screen
placed in shops.
So this one was our
first siging idea,
but we had to make big pivots
in Le Camping, Toulouse.
Thanks to La Camping
Toulouse because we
love to think about the
market, and the time to market.
And this was a
program of our idea.
And now--
MARTIN GORNER: So you
went to actual shops
and you pitched
them this solution.
You told them,
well, buy a screen
and put this little box next
to it, and it will do wonders.
It will do this and that.
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
It was the idea.
And you can manage
another business,
which is digital signage,
simple digital signage
or other companies like
[INAUDIBLE] schools.
Everyone can enjoy your
system in it's company.
There is now screens, in fact.
MARTIN GORNER: So it's better
to sell to companies who already
have those screens, because
then they only install
your little box, and that little
box is actually pretty cheap.
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
When we did that
pivot, we thought
about what do we
really have now.
And we had a platform,
a web platform
where you can send your
content, your ideas, your photos
online or display on screens.
We had a fantastic generator
of content, of ideas.
The idea is showing it.
And we had the real time
management of screen
based on the smallest per year.
And this was the
beginning of the story
because this player is pretty
compatible with most screens.
We don't sell screens.
We say, OK, you have screens.
Let's plug CityMeo in it.
MARTIN GORNER: So I
would like to show
a little demo of the content
creation part on CityMeo.
Actually here I'm on
the CityMeo website.
And let's say I want
to create a video
and put that video on all the
screens I have around my shop.
So let's pick this sample.
I'm going to play the video.
So it says, discover
the CityMeo experience.
100% products from Toulouse.
CityMeo.
And now if I want to modify
this video, this is the editor.
Actually what I can change
is the background picture
and those three messages.
So it's extremely simple to
create those kinds of videos.
And you have a ton of
presets with various styles
and specialized messages
for opening times,
for announcements, for
product promotions, and so on.
So Gary.
What do you think
about this pilot?
GARY CIGE: Well I
do know the company,
but I think it's
quite interesting,
because you are basically
moving outside, let's say,
the classical web
advertisement system
and you go to the online.
I'm a bit curious about
the distribution part.
Basically the box
is a simple box
connected to the internet
that is streaming something
on the TV screen.
Is that it?
The box is not a
very complex item.
But how, for the moment,
do you sell the product?
How do you distribute it?
Do you do it by yourself?
Do you go in the shops?
Do you do phoning?
I'm a bit curious about
how you do it now,
or a how you plan to
basically scale up.
Because that's always
the trickiest part.
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
Of course, this is the problem
with the original idea.
We cannot go in every shop
to speak to every shopkeeper
and say, hey, we
have a cool product.
We can't manage it, so now we
are dealing with big companies.
I have let's say 100 shops when
there is one screen per shop,
and they will be able to
manage that content everywhere
in each individual
shop from one platform.
So we can manage to reach
the top level of directions,
and then we have a
bigger [INAUDIBLE].
MARTIN GORNER: And how
about the physical part?
Because you're building
a hardware product.
How did you start with that?
DAVID KERIBIN: In fact, the only
thing we do here in Toulouse
is to assemble the [INAUDIBLE].
It's quite tricky
because we can't just
make 100 [INAUDIBLE] a
week right now because we
are as much as we could be.
But it's going well right now.
I think later we
will [INAUDIBLE]
as soon as possible.
MARTIN GORNER: You mean you're
assembling them yourself?
DAVID KERIBIN: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: Really.
All right.
DAVID KERIBIN: Not really
hard, but time consuming.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes.
You're going to
have to scale that.
GARY CIGE: Indeed.
I was a bit curious, how
many are you in the team?
Who is taking care
of the hardware
and who is taking
care of the software?
What do you take care of
because we only see you?
And I guess if you
are doing everything,
even assembling the product,
you don't have enough time.
DAVID KERIBIN: We have a
core team here in Toulouse,
and everyone has his
own parts of the story.
So I make the
business parts of it.
And [INAUDIBLE] is the website.
And associates, my
first associates
in making the video platform.
So there is a motion
designer and also
an engineer who can
manage to do this.
My other associate
is making the website
working and doing
direction with the user.
And the last one is
making the product,
the heart of the product.
So we are complementary.
GARY CIGE: I was a bit curious
because the issue with hardware
companies always
that just to begin
with you have to be
around three or four,
which is always a challenge to
create that kind of company.
So I was a bit curious as
to where, three, four, five,
or-- But that's a good mix.
MARTIN GORNER: And
how is business?
DAVID KERIBIN: It's
quite good because we
launched our product in January.
February our first client,
March, national clients.
So it's quite OK right now.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
Thank you very much David.
Thank you.
And now--
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Martin,
can I add something?
MARTIN GORNER: Yes of course.
GUILLAUME MARTIN: Yeah.
I just want to say,
as we're opening up
applications for the
company in Toulouse.
We just opened them
and everyone is welcome
if they have the
balls to come here.
MARTIN GORNER: Well
actually Gary, you
should say that
we're also opening
applications for Le Camping.
GARY CIGE: Yeah.
But I don't want to
compete with Guillaume.
[LAUGHTER]
First, let's fill in the
Toulouse applications
and then we are going
to take the rest.
MARTIN GORNER: So to
sum it up, applications
are now open for both Le Camping
in Toulouse and in Paris.
Please apply And now we are
coming back to the studio here,
and I have with me Romain
Cochet from SMIIRL.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yes.
Hello.
Hello everyone.
MARTIN GORNER: And before you
say anything, let's watch this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So Romain, what is this?
ROMAIN COCHET: What is this?
So it's a flag.
So we are Smiirl and we
are making this product.
It's a connected
object which displays
the number of your fans
directly on the object.
We are targeting
restaurants, shops, bars,
we call that break in models.
And actually today when
you enter into a shop,
you can see if these people
have a community behind them.
So the idea now is to display
it and to attract more fans
on your web page.
MARTIN GORNER: And so what I
see, this piece of hardware
is actually very well designed.
How did it look
before you started
working on it at
Le Camping here?
ROMAIN COCHET: So when
we came to Le Camping
it was only made
in the laser cut,
so your could see through it.
We only had the prototype
which was working,
but it was not efficient.
And we had to resolve
a lot of problems
before having this project.
MARTIN GORNER: And at what
stage of that development
did you think it was good
enough to go show to customers
and install in a shop?
ROMAIN COCHET: You have to
show it as quickly as possible,
because when you start
to design something,
you have to think how
the people will use it.
So when we came
to Le Camping, we
had the first idea of how
the object would look.
But at first, we didn't
have the glass for example.
And when we went to a shop, we
put it into a shop and someone
just say, oh, that's fine.
That's great.
And he put his
finger into the flags
and the object was broken.
So we decided to add
the glass to the object.
One thing is you have
to test it on your user.
And it's very [INAUDIBLE] if
you're doing this with other.
MARTIN GORNER: And
so the hardware part.
I'm a software engineer.
I don't get hardware.
Explain to me what
is the process
of making a hardware product,
designing it, prototyping it,
manufacturing it.
How does that work?
ROMAIN COCHET: So it's
quite complicated.
You have to understand
a lot of things
to do a product like this.
You first have to
think about the design
and think about the user.
It's the same as a website.
You have to think about
the user and sell it
to the good customer.
And you have to
answer a problem.
And after, when
you do your design,
you can start to do your
prototype like this.
You can show to customers,
to investors, to a community,
When you have that, you have
to [INAUDIBLE] the object
to be able to be produced.
Because when you
do a prototype, you
can take half a day
to do one of it.
But when you have to give
the product to your user,
you have to be able to
do a lot in one day.
So you have to rethink the
object, rethink the prototype,
and then go to see manufacturers
who will be able to produce it.
MARTIN GORNER: And do we
have manufacturers in France?
ROMAIN COCHET: Yes.
So when we started, we
had to do our first-
so when we entered Le Camping,
the first question that we have
is how many objects
will we send.
And we didn't know if we had to
do 10 objects, or 500 objects,
or 10,000, or much more.
And so that's why it
was very useful to be
at Le Camping for that.
And today we have a
factory in France.
We have a supply chain.
We have [INAUDIBLE] who
is coming from Toulouse.
We have the printing
which is made in--
MARTIN GORNER:
It's made of wood?
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
We have a small--
MARTIN GORNER: Oh yes, I see.
The front panel is made of wood.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
The front.
MARTIN GORNER: Very nice.
ROMAIN COCHET: And
we have the plastic,
which is made in [INAUDIBLE].
It's a French product for now.
But it's not enough for us.
We can't deliver
a lot of product
in the current
supply chain, so we
are looking for a better one.
GARY CIGE: And my
question is basically
for a hardware company, what
is the biggest challenge?
If you have to
name just one, what
is basically the
biggest thing to tackle?
ROMAIN COCHET: I think
one of the biggest things
is distribution,
like said Guillaume.
Because when you sell an object,
you have a lot of obstacles,
but they are in steps.
So the first one is to be
able to produce the object.
It's very complicated to
have a price of you're
object because you have to
enter into all the details
how do you inject plastic,
how you have to do molding,
you have to do toning.
So you have a financial problem.
So it's different when
you're a startup like us when
you have only
$10,000 your product.
GARY CIGE: And my
second question
is that it's really-- because
with that type of hardware
product usually you go
and you do crowd funding,
and you decided not to do it.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
GARY CIGE: Could you explain
a bit the process of reasoning
behind that choice?
ROMAIN COCHET: Yes.
When we thought
about that, we say,
oh, we can go on
Kickstarter and Testa
where there's a market for that.
But after [INAUDIBLE]
are shops, are retailers
and they are not
really on Kickstarter.
So we wanted to do
[INAUDIBLE] on our website
to be able to say, oh,
look, there is a market.
And we didn't touch
the geek person
who is one who are very close
to the technology [INAUDIBLE].
We want to touch the
real one, and test
if we can sell a
product like this.
So that's why we all didn't
choose to go on Kickstarter.
But Kickstarter and
all the other platforms
are very good to test the market
if you are into B2C model.
GARY CIGE: OK.
MARTIN GORNER: How
about the price point?
How do you nail the right price
point for something like this?
ROMAIN COCHET: For
the price point,
there is two
options of doing it.
At first, we didn't have
time to think about,
to do market studies, how many
people will be able to pay.
So what we think is
for the first price,
we decided to evaluate
the cost and say, OK, this
is our target cost.
And we will have to
have whole margin
to be able to live after.
We have to be able
to have a margin
to distribute the object.
And yeah, so that's quite easy.
You do your estimation after
you do your [INAUDIBLE] margin,
the distributor margin,
and that's quite-- yes.
MARTIN GORNER: Well,
yes, but it also has
to correspond to a price
point that the customers
are ready to pay.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
After, when you have this
price point, you can test it.
You can go on shops [INAUDIBLE],
and if people are saying,
OK, we are OK to buy it for
this price, that's fine.
And we tested like that.
At first, when we
started we decided
to fix the price at 300
euros without the taxes.
And we went to shop [INAUDIBLE]
and saying, OK, it's 300 euros.
Is that so much?
And they say, oh no.
My chair here is
only 200 euros or so.
That's fine.
I have 20 chairs like this,
so 300 euros is fine for me.
GARY CIGE: But that's
the tricky part.
We worked a lot on
the price point.
testing because this
is a product that you
can actually easily test.
Because you just go in the
street and you test it.
And they were quite
effective on that.
And the project changed a lot.
The product changed.
The price changed.
And I was also a bit curious
because you basically
sold 500 of them,
and quite quickly.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
GARY CIGE: And what has been
the effect at the customers?
Because you sell something
like, improve your communication
with your client.
What the effect of this
for your customers?
ROMAIN COCHET: So the benefit
of the customers-- here we are.
Today we are shipping the
first objects in two months.
And we see the feedback
of the customer
and say, oh that's
great, because I
have 10 people who are
stopping behind my shop.
And I have more
fans on my web page
and on my Facebook
account, and then I
can reach them more
easily than before.
So that was the
idea of the object,
and now we are seeing that
it's becoming ready to them.
GARY CIGE: You actually
changed the transformation rate
of those shops?
ROMAIN COCHET: Yeah.
And the fist thing
that a customer does
is just to open the box
and put it on the website.
And the first day he
say, oh, do you like me
on Facebook, our Facebook page?
And we can see that
they have 20 or 40
more followers in the same day.
So that's crazy.
That's really working.
GARY CIGE: And what's next?
So you sold 500, which was
not the final objective
of the company.
ROMAIN COCHET: Yes.
So there is two parts.
The first part is make
this product more reliable
and sell it in mass production.
So thanks to Le Camping,
we met Orange and we
went to [INAUDIBLE]
with them to see
how can we manufacture
this kind of product.
And also we are-- Smiirl stands
for social media integrated
in real life.
And the idea is just to bring
back all this social media
and [INAUDIBLE]
into the real life,
and there's a lot of call to do.
We are three people.
There's Gauthier,
who is our CEO.
He was an advertiser.
There is Raphael,
who is a designer.
And I am a CTO on the
hardware and software parts.
And this mix is made
to create new objects.
And we want to go
further in the way
how we interact with reality.
MARTIN GORNER: So we
should be expecting
more connected
objects from Smiirl.
ROMAIN COCHET: Exactly.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank
you very much, Romain.
ROMAIN COCHET:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN GORNER:
Thank you, Romain.
Thank you, Gary.
Thank you everyone in
Toulouse and Berlin.
And this is the
end of the stream.
Thank you everyone for
watching this first live stream
from the NUMA Studio.
GARY CIGE: Thank you.
ROMAIN COCHET: Thank you.
JEREMY BAMBERG: Thank you.
VALENTINA: Bye.